arztpraxis zentrum fiona hefti
guten tag frau heft die mein name ist
jörg spanier kurz eschborn ii wie kann
ich ihnen helfen
ich bin krank mir geht es schlecht
ich fühle mich nicht gut
ich bin krank mir geht es schlecht ich
fühle mich nicht gut
ich möchte einen termin vereinbaren
sind sie das erste mal bei uns patient
nein ich war schon öfter bei ihnen
ja ich bin das erste mal bei ihnen
[Musik]
ja ich war noch nie bei ihnen
wie heißt ihr hausarzt
rudolf sallinger rudolf sallinger können
sie mir bitte ihre kranken
versicherungsnummer geben
[Musik]
können sie mir bitte ihre kranken
versicherungsnummer geben
meine krankenversicherungs nummer ist
60 43 78 21 9 560 4 378 2 195 was haben
sie für symptome was haben sie
was haben sie für symptome was haben sie
[Musik]
ich habe
schmerzen ich habe kopfschmerzen
mein kopf tut wie mein kopf tut weh
ich habe bauchschmerzen ich habe
bauchschmerzen
mein bauch tut weh mein bauch tut weh
ich habe halsschmerzen ich habe
halsschmerzen
mein hals tut wie mein hals tut weh
ich habe rückenschmerzen ich habe
rückenschmerzen
mein rücken tut weh mein rücken tut weh
ich habe ohrenschmerzen ich habe
ohrenschmerzen
meine ohren tun weh meine ohren tun weh
eine biene
stocher eine biene hat mich gestochen
jetzt kann ich nicht richtig atmen
ich habe mühe beim atmen
meine augen sind angeschwollen
meine augen sind entzündet
ich habe fieber ich habe fieber
ich bin rk
ich bin erkältet mir ist schlecht
mir ist schlecht
mir ist schwindelig
ich fühle mich
schwach und müde ich fühle mich schwach
und müde
ich habe keine energie ich habe keine
energie
[Musik]
ich habe
eine allergie ich habe eine allergie
ich habe einen hautausschlag
ich kann nicht richtig schlucken ich
kann nicht richtig schlucken
ich musste erbrechen ich musste
erbrechen
ich habe durchfall ich habe durchfall
ich habe blut im urin
ich bin hin
ich bin hingefallen
jetzt tut mein bein wie jetzt tut mein
bein w
jetzt tut mein knie weh jetzt tut mein
knie weh
[Musik]
jetzt tut meine hüfte wie jetzt tut
meine hüfte wie
jetzt kann ich mein knie nicht richtig
bewegen
ich hatte vor einem jahr eine
knieoperation
ich hatte vor zwei jahren eine operation
am knie ich hatte vor zwei jahren eine
operation am knie
jetzt habe ich dort schmerzen
[Musik]
moment ich schaue nach wann herr doktor
zollinger einen termin frei hat
übermorgen am mittwoch um 13 uhr
[Musik]
nein das ist viel zu spät
nein
das ist viel zu spät
es ist dringend es ist ein notfall
ich habe starke schmerzen ich kann nicht
warten
geht das nicht früher ich brauche heute
noch einen termin
[Musik]
herr doktor zollinger ist total
ausgebucht
wenn es dringend ist hat frau dr küchen
in einer stunde einen termin frei
wenn es dringend ist hat frau dr büchen
um 9 uhr 30 um 9 uhr 30
ja das geht vielen dank
gut ich trage sie für 9 uhr 30 bei frau
dr büchi 1
rufen sie einen arzt rufen sie einen
arzt rufen sie die ambulanz rufen sie
die ambulanz
gehen sie zum arzt gehen sie zum arzt
geht zum arzt geht zum arzt
kaufen sie in der apotheke ein
medikament kaufen sie in der apotheke
ein medikament
kauf in der apotheke ein medikament kauf
in der apotheke ein medikament
ruh dich aus du dich aus
schon dich schon dich
holen sie sich ausruhen sie sich aus
schonen sie sich schonen sie sich
nehmen sie das medikament jeden tag
nimm das medikament jeden tag nimmt das
medikament jeden tag
trinken sie mehr wasser trinken sie mehr
wasser
trinkt mehr wasser trinkt mehr wasser
arbeiten sie weniger arbeiten sie
weniger
arbeite weniger arbeite weniger
essen sie gesünder essen sie gesünder
ist gesünder ist gesünder
treiben sie sport treiben sie sport
treibt sport treibt sport
vergiss nicht das medikament zu nehmen
vergessen sie nicht das medikament zu
nehmen
hilfe hilfe helfen sie mir
helfen sie mir
[Musik]
hilf mir hilf mir
nicht vergessen dieses video zu liken zu
kommentieren und zu teilen
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video